Hey what's up guys, my name is The Cherno! Welcome
back to the third episode of my Ray Tracing series.
So last time we spent pretty much the whole
episode talking about math i highly highly
recommend that you take a look at that episode
even if you're not interested in math because
the whole spirit of the series obviously is
learning how to do absolutely everything and
knowing how everything works and i think for ray
tracing specifically like this is such a good
opportunity to actually dive deep into how stuff
works on paper map it all out understand it and
then translate that into like code and see images
appear from nothing which is just super cool now
what we're going to do here today is building
on the math that we actually worked out on paper
last episode we're going to take the exact same
like equations put them into c plus plus and have
them render a sphere for us the really cool thing
about today's episode is again it's going to be
identical to the stuff that we did on paper last
episode but you're going to see it kind of applied
you know per pixel to actually render an image
but to make that happen and also make this a
little bit more like sustainable for the future
as our code gets more complicated i want to dive
into the existing code that we've got and kind
of restructure it a little bit so that we have
basically this concept of a renderer so over here
inside our ray tracing project let's go ahead and
make a new file and we're going to make two new
files actually called renderer.h and renderer.cpp
now one of my goals with this series is to keep
things as practical as possible so i don't want
to spend like too much time talking about like the
architecture of a renderer or anything like that
like this is not really the purpose of this series
we don't have a namespace do we i wanted i wanted
a name for this but i don't think we have one at
the moment so let's just go ahead and write the
class without a namespace so what i mean is like
i don't really want to put too much emphasis on
like how to design a renderer you know for a ray
tracer or for a real-time application or whatever
we're going to just keep things as simple as
possible and so the purpose of this really is it's
going to be a class which holds some context but
the idea is the input is a scene description so
we have like some form of description of like the
3d world that we're trying to render and then the
output is an image which holds the pixels that the
renderer has produced which describe that scene
so fundamentally that is like the purpose of this
class and this whole kind of architecture now at
the moment we really don't have a scene in fact if
we run the current state of our application it is
this we just have a bunch of random pixels which
basically just proves that we have the ability to
write to a vulcan image and then display it using
imgui every single frame that's what we're doing
here which will look much better like in real
life and not in a youtube video because of the
compression now because of that we're not really
going to have an input at the moment but in the
future this will take in like a scene which is
going to basically be something that holds like
the description of our scene like meaning like
all of the objects inside the scene you know stuff
like a light environment and all of that stuff but
for now we're just going to have a kind of empty
constructor now this constructor will have stuff
in the future but for now i'm just going to keep
it as just equals default just so it is there now
the real the real function of this renderer at the
moment is going to be this render function which
literally is going to do all of the work so the
goal here is to basically render like every pixel
that we have that makes up that viewport that you
saw there which currently has random pixels now
because of the way that this is going to work the
target of that render function is going to be an
actual image so i'm going to go ahead and include
walnut image and then we're going to similarly
how we like basically had this image here right i
don't really want to have the image just inside
walnut app.cpp we're going to move this image
to being inside this renderer class let's also
include memory so that we can use shared pointers
and this is going to be a walnut image now i'm
deliberately like not you know putting this into
the walnut namespace or using namespace or
anything like that i don't wanna do any of
that because i wanted to be clear like what stuff
is from walnut and what stuff is our stuff that
we're writing as part of this series now going
back though to our main kind of walnut app class
there are obviously a fair few things here that
are really important for us to take with us for
example before we render we check to see what the
viewport width and height actually is because we
want to be able to render an image that is the
same size as our viewport and if the viewport size
has changed which is what this function does over
here it will actually create a brand new image
with that new width and height so that's obviously
important stuff that we need to make sure that we
actually do inside this renderer class somewhere
i think what i'll do for now is i will just make
like a on on resize function and this on resize
function we're just taking a width and height
now internally it's obviously going to know the
current width and height because an image actually
holds like a width and height so we can kind of
only do the resize if necessary and to make things
a little bit easier inside this function where
we'll basically do this we can check to see if the
okay well if there's no image we'll have to create
one anyway but basically we can check to see if
image get width obviously matches the width
and then if like the width hasn't changed and
if the height hasn't changed then of course
we don't need to resize the image now i have
actually added a new function into walnut called
resize and what this will do if we take a look at
its implementation you can see that it will
check first of all to see if the image even
needs resizing so it has the width and height is
the width and height different to what we already
have and if so then it's going to release and
then reallocate that memory so this is like just
a little bit easier to deal with than having to
completely like delete the image and create a new
one one of the reasons why i really like this
design as well is because the original kind of
image handle so to speak so in other words like
this image like its pointer doesn't change the
object doesn't change so everything that used to
hold a reference to image like as a shared pointer
obviously still has that same image because you're
not deleting the object and making a new one
which obviously will have a different like spot
in memory somewhere right you're actually keeping
that same object and then changing like the
insides basically which is what we're doing here
we're releasing it like from our gpu memory and
reallocating that gpu memory uh within this same
kind of object so i like that because it does
keep things uh quite a bit cleaner so ultimately
we need to do this but obviously if we don't have
the image in the first place then we're going to
have to create it and my plan by the way with
this is we're going to call renderer on resize
first so when we actually render over here what
we're really going to do is call like renderer
resize and then renderer render so we're going to
see if it needs resizing by just passing in the
viewport width and height and then we're going
to call the render function which will actually
render into into that image but the only flaw here
is that we do actually still need to create the
image in the first place if it doesn't exist so
i think i might change this just because resizing
will be the main case if there is an image then we
can just call image resize like this assuming that
it needs to be resized but again because this does
the check internally i'm going to just call resize
and then obviously if it doesn't need to it's
not going to resize it's not going to waste time
reallocating memory and then over here if there is
like no image in the first place then we obviously
need to create it with the width and the height
and then whatever format we want which we'll keep
as rgba for now now we also obviously have like a
cpu side buffer which represents like the data of
the actual image and that buffer is called image
data so we need to also take that with us so we're
going to come over here and grab image data and
we're going to put it into here and this is also
something that obviously we'll need to get like
initially created over here and then resize as
well so let's go ahead and delete it and then
we're going to basically just recreate it like
this and set it equal to width times height now
a few notes here obviously this actually doesn't
need to be called if we're not resizing the image
so even though this does have that check i'm going
to add it again here and we're not going to call
it if it doesn't need to resize but basically if
image get width equals width and image get height
equals height so in other words if the image is
already the right width and height if it's the
correct width and height then we'll just return if
there is an image as well so if there's no image
it will still create a new one obviously because
there is no image in the first place however if
if there is an existing image it will exit out of
this function if uh if there's no resize necessary
so we'll just say no resize necessary otherwise it
will resize the image then jump over here delete
the image data and then recreate that image data
as well now if image data is null as it will
be for the first time that's fine this will do
nothing and that's perfectly okay whenever there's
like a delete null pointer going on i always feel
the need to explain it because some people still
don't understand that it's totally valid to do
that and you don't need to do stuff like if if
image data delete it or anything like that because
the delete operator will actually free which it
will eventually call that that does that check
for you okay so we now have an image so render
uh i might actually drop this down just because
that's the order that they're going to get called
in so let's go ahead and basically move our image
generation code that we have at the moment into
that renderer class to make sure that everything's
working as we expect so we can delete the image
from here and in fact replace it with just a
renderer i'm going to go up here and obviously
include our renderer class that we just created
that will already be obviously instantiated with
the default constructor the only thing we need to
do is in render we need to call render resize as
that comment says with the width and the height
and then we just need to call render a render
and that is it so none of this needs to be done
this is our new like rendering code that i'm
going to take and put into the render function
so that's what we're what we're dealing
with here let's go ahead and grab the image
width and the image height and then random let's
come over here grab the random class we don't need
that there anymore and we'll just include it over
here this is going to be walnut random so that's
our image data and then obviously to actually set
that into the vulcan texture we also need to call
image set data which we will do after we after
we've gone through and set that uh cpu side buffer
filled it with our random pixels um yeah and
then we can keep last render time okay so this
this stuff now becomes basically if renderer get
final image as we'll call it so let's go back
to the renderer i'm actually going to call this
final image and not image the reason being that
um it's possible that we're probably going to
have more than one image in like our kind of
render pass pipeline because we might do like
some post processing so um for that reason i'm
just going to call it final images so that it's
clear that this image uh just make sure that where
we've renamed it everywhere because that this this
image is in fact like kind of our final buffer
after the rendering is complete that's like the
final resulting image that we want to probably
take and then display so let's go ahead
and write a function called get final image
and then that will return final image back in
walnut app if final image is a thing in fact i
might just call this auto image equals get final
image really should i don't know this this stuff
is new this like showing me what the types are
i don't know where that and it did not tell it
to pop up but it's popping up now so i don't
know maybe i'll disable it although i guess
it might be useful i don't know let me know what
you guys think like for videos is this useful to
like know the the parameters or whatever i don't
generally like it too much when i'm programming
um okay so render is undefined for some reason
this i think is size so i think we're just missing
a kelly bracket and that's probably why okay cool
so that is looking pretty good i think that's
it so just to summarize what we've just done is
some very light refactoring we've just moved all
of our renderer related things into a renderer
class that will also kind of act as like the
the thing that will accept our scene and we'll
output a final image that we can then just take
and um and display in our viewport so if we
hit f5 hopefully we'll get the same result
or a compile error so i somehow got rid of that i
don't know things went things got got weird when
we started refactoring that that part um okay
cool so we've got the same result obviously and
everything is fantastic okay so now that we've
done that let's dive back into the renderer class
and take a little bit of a look at how how to kind
of architect this part of it a little bit better
so if you've done any kind of gpu programming
like using vulkan opengl directx anything like
that you're probably familiar with the concept
of pixel shaders or fragment shaders and these
are basically just gpu programs that will run for
every pixel of whatever you're trying to render so
when triangles get rasterized every pixel that is
generated as a as a result of that rasterization
process will invoke like an instance of this
pixel shader and a shader is just a name for
a gpu program so what i want to do with this code
is i actually want to structure it to be a little
bit more like that so in other words i want us to
effectively be able to write like a pixel shader
over here in c plus plus another great example
of this is shader toy so shader toy is a website
where you can basically write like a pixel shader
and you will get the result rendering over here in
real time so you can see that we have like a pixel
shader over here this is kind of the format that
we write it in so you can see that we've got it
looks like it looks like a single function doesn't
have like a for loop in it or anything however
this this exact code gets invoked for every pixel
of this viewport that we're rendering here and an
important feature of this is you can see we can
we have like a uv coordinate now in this case the
uv coordinate if we just output the uv coordinate
alone let's add in a z value of like zero then
this is what the uv coordinate will look like
so we've simplified it a bit let's get rid of all
the extra stuff this is as simple as it is really
what this is showing us is a value between zero
and one across the x-axis which is being displayed
as the red channel and then from zero to one along
the y-axis which is being displayed as the green
channel that's why you see it get greener as you
get higher up because that value goes from zero to
one and one is full green 255 in an rgba buffer
or i should say in like a one byte per channel
kind of integer format and then obviously with
the x axis it gets more red as you go kind of
in the positive x direction because again it goes
from zero all the way to one and in the top right
corner where we have one on the x and one on the
y we see yellow because that's the combination
of the red and green channel on full blast and
then no blue because we put in zero for blue
and then alpha is one this specific setup over
here is going to be really really useful to us
and it's going to simplify a lot of things so
i want to basically be able to write this exact
program as it is as it appears here in the format
it appears here which means no four loop nothing
like that but inside our c plus boss code so let's
make that happen so what i'm going to do is write
a function i'm going to just make it private for
now we'll call it per pixel just so it's clear and
it's going to return a uint32t which is going to
be our resulting color now it's going to take in
a glm vector which is going to be our coordinate
so what this is going to be is essentially the
frag coordinate that you see here now it's going
to be a little bit different because it's actually
already going to be in this format but basically
what frag quad is as an input is it's just like
the pixel coordinate in pixel space in other
words this would be like the resolution is 1200
by 675 and so we would have a coordinate like
in that range like the middle would be like 600
that's why you're seeing this kind of division
here where it's dividing frag coord which is
in pixel space by the resolution which of course
is 1200 by 675 to map it into like a zero to one
range so that is already going to be the input
here it's going to be already in that zero to
one range in fact we're actually going to change
it a bit later on to be in a negative one to one
range because that is even more useful so let's go
ahead and implement this function now as you can
imagine what we need to do now is simply call this
function from like within a for loop like this
so that kind of our goal but from here we actually
need to work out this coordinate so to make things
a little bit easier to understand i'm actually
going to convert this to be a nested for loop
where we're going to iterate through the y which
of course is going to be like the outer for loop
that's going to be the height of our image here
and then the inner for loop is going to be x
now the reason why we write y on the outside
here is because we want to be we want to be
more friendly with the cpu cache essentially so
the reason why this is important is because if
you think about the way that the buffer is
laid out in memory as we go like one un32t
forwards we're going to essentially be going
horizontally across the image if we had
flipped this then it would be a bit weird
because we'd be skipping a bunch of memory
by basically going like a full row forwards
and that's going to actually slow down our
program because the cpu is not going to be able
to fetch that memory as easily but anyway once we
have this kind of nested for loop where we have
like the x and y we can easily work out what the
coordinates should be so our coordinate is just
really going to be whatever x is divided by that
total width of the image so we can divide
it here and then the same thing for our y
coordinate as well of course but with height now
there's a fatal flaw in this and that is the fact
that these are both integers and so when we do an
integer division here it's really only going to be
zero like for all of these so we need to make sure
that we cast at least one of them like this to a
float and then it will do a proper floating point
division just for completeness sake though i like
to do both of them although just one is necessary
okay so we now have a coordinate that we can pass
into per pixel and then the result here is going
to be image data that color that per pixel returns
we're going to store inside the image data buffer
at the appropriate location which speaking of
like what is the appropriate location because
we don't have that i variable anymore well we
can easily convert this kind of two-dimensional
coordinate x and y back into that one-dimensional
offset of that buffer by just doing x plus y times
whatever the width is because what this is doing
is just multiplying like the y-coordinate by like
how how big each row like supposedly is and then
just adding in that like x column offset so
now it's the responsibility of per pixel to
actually provide some kind of color and just to do
something extremely easy let's just set this to be
magenta so we're going to have a nice pink color
here and i'm actually going to come over here and
also include glm because we need that since we're
referencing vector over here so let's go ahead and
hit f5 and hopefully we'll see that pink viewport
and there it is now since we did just convert our
whole program to be very much like shader toy why
don't we try this exact example so uv is already
there that's our coordinate so really we should
just be able to set frag color to vect4 uv 0 and 1
right now we're using integers for now as like our
colors so it's going to be a little bit different
we'll have to actually convert into that but
ultimately we're going to switch to using floating
point images eventually i'm almost tempted to
just do it now i think we'll do it next time
though just so that we can keep things like it was
originally but to make this happen ultimately what
we would need to do is just simply grab like the
red channel which we'll set equal to x if we just
multiply that with 255 and then cast that to be
like a byte like that then that will give us our
red channel and our green channel will be chord
dot y and then we need to basically shove this
into here so let's go ahead and make something
like that and then we'll or in g shifted left 16
or actually eight and then red over here so that
i think should be correct no it's black no whoops
i forgot to add in more zeros okay there we
go so you can see we get the same result it's
actually flipped upside down though so you can
see that that kind of black area is over here
and the yellow area is over here now the reason
for that is actually to do with how i am gui
displays our image so if we go back to here what
i'm actually going to do is add one more parameter
here which was originally optional and that is the
uv 0 and uv 1 parameters and what i'm going to do
is basically set maybe i'll just drop this down so
it's more visible i'm going to set the uv 0 to be
0 1 instead of 0 0 and the uv 1 to be 1 0 instead
of 1 1. so basically what i've done is i've just
reversed the uv coordinate of the y axis here
so that v of the uv has now just been inverted
basically and that will flip our image now there's
a bunch of different ways that you can flip this
image to be honest you could you could change
so many things but this is just the easiest way
to do it and that's what i usually do okay so
if we run this again now you can see we have a
result which perfectly matches what we actually
see here and we also should be able to resize if
that's something i didn't actually check and you
can see that that also obviously works and gives
us kind of our expected range of colors here so
that is really really important stuff because
this kind of coordinate system that i've just
shown you here and also this function here which
we can use to render things per pixel this is
going to form the basis of how we actually decide
where to shoot out our rays like from the camera
to see if they intersect with our sphere which is
what we're about to do so now things are pretty
simple we have the coordinates and we're able
to run some calculations for every single pixel
which makes up our viewport so this is now where
the math comes back in so this is the math that
we did in the last episode as a quick recap what
we know is that the equation of a circle is over
here here it is the equation of like a ray is this
thing over here and we can basically substitute
this into this to do all of this math and more or
less get like this final final equation before
we actually substituted some some real values
to see if we could actually get our array to
intersect with our circle so if you haven't
watched that math episode then definitely watch it
i'll have it linked up there but also if this kind
of math interests you and if you want to learn
more then i can't recommend anything better than
the sponsor of this video and this ray tracing
series brilliant so brilliant is an amazing
website with lots of different courses on various
stem topics and their math courses are literally
the best i've found so far on the internet and
the reason for that is because they're extremely
engaging interactive and practical they don't
just throw information at you have you watch
videos do all that stuff they actually give you
like interactive controls to play with so you
can visually understand how stuff works which i
think is so important for the kind of math that
we're doing i mean we're literally using math
to like to create a ray tracer like we're using
math to create images like that is like the most
visual thing ever and to be honest like pretty
much all math is like that it's just that a lot of
platforms and a lot of different courses out there
they don't they don't fully take advantage of
this fact and me being like a very visual learner
i just think that that's by far the best the best
way to learn they've got lots of different math
courses which cover pretty much every inch of what
we're going to be doing in this rage racing series
and these are all just really high quality courses
these calculus courses for example benefits so
much from this kind of visual interaction
brilliant also have plenty of courses on
other stem topics so if you're interested in like
computer science data structures just general
science as well and the applications of that
lots of stuff there to check out and speaking
of checking it out you can get started for free
by just going to my link in description below
but brilliant have also been nice enough
to offer the first 200 of my subscribers 20
off an annual membership all you have to do is
go to the link description below and sign up
so go ahead check them out see if there are any
courses you're interested in huge thank you as
always to brilliant for sponsoring this video okay
so once you have brilliant it up and you've also
gone back and watched that previous episode of the
ray tracing series and you understand all of this
it's finally time to take these weird equations
and put them into c plus plus so where do we even
begin with that well okay let's kind of break this
down because there are a few differences between
the equations and what we're actually doing here
first of all i did mention that we of course did
the math in 2d whereas over here with our ray
tracing we're going to be obviously doing this
in 3d now the difference is so small again that it
really doesn't matter we just add in that extra z
axis the z dimension so what we need to do here
is fairly simple we need to take this equation
this bx squared plus by squared t squared plus
2ax this equation over here and then just just
substitute the values the same way we did here
with actual like variables and then we can use
this quadratic formula to solve this equation just
like we did on paper but we can obviously just do
this like nc plus plus so the first thing i
want to do is just write out this equation
as like a comment over here just so that it's
clear what we're doing the only thing that we
actually already substituted here was this -4
which if you remember was the radius squares
i'm going to leave the radius squared alone and we
have this which as you can see is exactly the same
equation as we had on paper now there is one thing
we can do to simplify it very very slightly and
that is the fact that you can see that there's a
two at the front of both of these terms so what we
can actually do is remove it from there and just
kind of take it out like this we'll just do this
here to simplify the actual simplest code a little
bit so now that we have this remember t is what
we're solving for that is going to be the distance
along that ray we have all of these unknown
variables now the only real unknown variables
we have are a and b and r that's it so what is a
a is going to be our ray origin which going back
to our math we know that from that ray equation a
plus bt is what we kind of define these variables
as a would in fact be the origin of the ray and
b would be the direction of the ray so a is the
ray origin b is the ray direction r is the radius
of this sphere or circle doesn't really matter
though and t is like the hit distance we'll call
it so now all we have to do is fill these in
so let's go ahead and do that now i'm going to
name these variables a b and c just like they
appear in the quadratic equation so if we go
back to the quadratic equation and specifically
like the quadratic formula we have this kind of
a b and c inside the quadratic formula and a b
and c obviously they map to the actual values
the actual coefficients of the different parts of
this quadratic equation so the coefficient of t
squared is a the coefficient of t is b and
then finally that constant term here is our c
term so that's why i'm i'm going to name these a
b and c so in other words this is going to be a
this is going to be b and then this is going to be
c so what is a a is b x squared plus b y squared
now what you see here is just x and y there's no
z because we were doing this in terms of a circle
but that's how you add z it's just an extra term
there like wherever we had x you can see that we
obviously split everything up by x and y right we
have x and then we have y we have x and then we
have y we have x and then we have y well z is just
like an additional term there so what that means
is that what this is going to be here it's going
to basically be the ray direction like squared so
multiplied with itself and then all like summed up
together so the first question we have then is if
we really do want to figure this out like what on
earth is going to be that right direction and this
is where we're going to talk about how we should
raise out from the ray origin in the first place
now because i wanted this episode to be kind of
not too long we'll say i'm not going to spend a
huge amount of time talking about how to shoot
raise out all i'm going to tell you is that if
we have our camera over here we can say that this
is just at like 0 0 0 doesn't really matter then
all we have to do to calculate array per pixel is
effectively just use this coordinate that we have
but remember it's a bit weird because the current
way that the coordinate is set up it goes from
zero zero to one one which is a little bit weird
if you consider that to be like your direction if
this is our camera here and we're looking kind of
along the same axis that it's looking at it means
we'd kind of shoot all of our arrays this way and
and nothing would kind of go around right so what
we can do is remap these coordinates to be from
negative one to one rather than being from zero to
one and we can do that really really easily when
we figure out this coordinate what we can do is
just multiply the coordinate by two and subtract
one and of course that will just remap it from
being from zero to one to being from negative one
to one and that will kind of make sure the zero is
kind of down the middle and all these other rays
kind of go out out along like different sides now
for a lot of reasons this is not really the final
solution that we'll stick with but it's a really
easy way to just get started and it will totally
work we could normalize that as well if we wanted
to make sure that they're all the same length
because obviously at the moment they won't be
so what that means for us here is this coordinate
really is our ray direction so let's get started
implementing this equation so it's going to be
coordinate x squared plus coordinate y squared
plus coordinate z squared because we are in 3d
space but wait you say that's a vector so how do
we deal with this so if we go back to what we drew
here what we're kind of looking at here i mean
this is a 2d image so of course it's easy to just
deal with two kind of dimensions two axes but if
we picture this being like the actual coordinate
of each pixel on the viewport if we were to like
obviously rotate this onto its side so not this
this kind of whole thing this plane gets rotated
90 degrees onto the side it would just look like
that so these rays all at the moment kind of
just they have no depth to them obviously what
we want to do is we want to kind of shoot them
that way so the camera is facing a particular
direction and we want to shoot the rays that
way so apart from being all across this area we
want them to actually have depth so that you know
if we do rotate them if we rotate this view like
this we actually see them have depth like that
so the way that we can do that very easily is
just by adding a z-coordinate adding a z-axis
to our ray and then like setting it to like one
or negative one depending on which way we define
our forward to be now for this example it's
actually not going to matter if it's positive
one or negative one not gonna matter at all
we're going to just use negative one for now
just because that's a if you're used to like
opengl that's a very kind of common way of
thinking about your forward direction and really
this comes down to whether you're dealing with a
right-handed coordinate system or a left-handed
coordinate system but again for now we're not
going to care about any of that what we're going
to say is that our three-dimensional ray direction
is going to be coordinate dot x coordinate dot y
and negative one so there's that negative one on
the z and then obviously these are going to also
be between negative one and one and then if we
want that to be a unit vector we can normalize it
now this is not going to matter for now either so
we'll leave that off for now just so that you can
see the result okay so now we're obviously going
to change this to be our ray direction now this
is looking pretty big and if you've been paying
attention to your your vector math you may have
noticed that what we've written out here is just
the dot product of ray direction with itself so
we're squaring each term and then summing them all
up to get a nice float so we can rewrite this as
just being glm dot ray direction and ray direction
just like that and that's it that's the same
thing and you can see over here we're also going
to have another dot product but this time with
the ray origin but we'll get to that eventually
so this is our a term now that's it it's just ray
direction dot ray direction that's the kind of a
coefficient of our quadratic equation now let's
move on to this kind of b coefficient so what's
this going to be so flow b is going to be 2 times
ax bx so what is this this is the array origin x
times the ray direction x plus the ray origin
y times the ray direction y and then obviously
it's going to be the same for z so this is also
a dot product because we're multiplying each
component of a with each component of b and then
summing them all up so this is just going to be
the dot of whatever a is which is our ray origin
which we haven't really defined let's define that
again i'm just going to make it zero as i did
in my diagram it's just going to be reorigin dot
ray direction and that's it that's our b so simple
and then c is going to be this last part over here
which is going to be the ray origin dot itself but
then we're going to subtract the radius squared so
let's go ahead and define a radius for our sphere
i'll just set it to 0.5 so we basically have like
a one unit diameter sphere and then we should
be able to sort this out so this is going to be
glm dot the ray origin with itself and then we're
going to subtract the radius squared so we'll
just do radius times radius that is our entire
quadratic equation written out here ready to be
plugged in to the quadratic formula so that it can
actually be solved so what we'll do today is we'll
just focus on the discriminant which remember
should be enough to see if we actually intersect
the sphere or not it will tell us if there are any
solutions so that part is b squared minus 4ac so
let me just write this out b squared minus
4ac so let's go ahead and calculate it here
discriminant so b squared is obviously going
to be b times b minus 4 times a times c
that's our discriminant and so guess what based
off of this we can now check to see if it's
greater than zero then there are solutions if it's
greater than or equal to zero there's at least one
solution and then if it's less than zero there
are no solutions so we can now use this to return
a color based on what the discriminant is right so
in other words if the discriminant is greater than
or equal to zero then we can return let's say that
magenta color otherwise we can return just black
i guess so black will be our background and then
if we hit the sphere we should see that magenta
color and that is it let's see what that looks
like okay so we just get a solid pink viewport
right which tells us that we're hitting the
sphere i mean i kind of maybe would have expected
to see a sphere in the middle i'm not sure why i
would have expected that just i would have right
but if you think about it this actually makes
perfect sense because where is our ray origin zero
where is our sphere origin zero so what's actually
happening is we're shooting rays out from here
and then we have this sphere that's here
so we're basically inside the sphere
and as we hit this of course we're hitting it this
entire sphere fills our viewport so what we need
to do to see the kind of image that we were maybe
expecting which i don't know about you guys but i
was expecting to see something like this with
the sphere in the middle we need to obviously
move this sphere we need to translate it back
along the negative axis the negative z axis
back in 3d space so that it doesn't fill our our
camera's viewport alternatively we could of course
just move the camera back so let's go ahead and
try that let's keep the x and y of the camera at
zero but let's move this back maybe like two
meters or something like that and negative two
of course would be moving it forward just like in
the direction of our ray so let's go ahead and set
this to positive two because that will be kind of
moving it back remember forward is negative z and
look at that we have a sphere we have ray traced
a sphere amazing hopefully this has shown you guys
just how cool this kind of practical application
of math really is because again we've gone from
literally like having this stuff on paper right
to being able to write it out programmatically
per pixel and actually draw this image and this
is just the beginning because remember what we
did on paper then later is we actually solved the
quadratic formula to work out the exact location
of the hit along the sphere because at the moment
it kind of looks like it could just be a circle
it's not we've obviously used that kind of
z uh dimension as well this is actually all
being calculated in 3d space this is in 3d it's
just it's very it's flatly lit so we can't tell
so what i want you guys to do for homework is
go in and see if you can solve the rest of the
quadratic formula then you'll get the actual like
ray hit distances see if you can work out the 3d
coordinate of everything and maybe even figure out
like the normal of the sphere and for bonus points
see if you can apply some shading to it to see
that it is in fact in 3d now this way of doing
things has like a bunch of flaws obviously and
like one of them is if we resize this viewport
you can see that it gets stretched why because
obviously there's no concept of like aspect ratio
or anything we're still in that zero to one space
both horizontally and vertically and by zero to
one in negative one to one so clearly we need to
account for like the the width of our viewport for
the aspect ratio of our viewport to kind of not
send raise out so that could be another little
homework assignment for you but yeah this is the
beginning this is the beginning of being able to
raytrace an image so let's go ahead and clean
it up a little bit i'll get rid of this stuff
i did say i would show you the kind of redirection
normalization but you're not going to be able
to tell the difference here it's going to look
exactly the same as you can see so it's not really
necessary it's just something that mathematically
to me seems like it should be but for this
specific thing it's not going to be necessary
when we start getting into actually solving the
quadratic formula then obviously the direction
and the actual length of that directional vector
is going to determine these t values and all
that stuff so it is a good idea to normalize
it potentially for some things if you need
accurate hit distances but uh you know for just
drawing this kind of part of it it's absolutely
fine so yeah that's the final code it'll be up on
the github page so feel free to download it and
run it on your computer and play around with it
another thing you could do as well by the way is
you can see that the equation of a circle actually
has this kind of a and b which is the origin of
the circle or origin of the sphere so see if you
can maybe move this sphere around we can obviously
move the camera around that's just the right
origin but of course it would also be like useful
to be able to move the sphere around so see if
you can work that part into the equation as well
but other than that that's that's it that's the
beginning of our ray tracing journey we finally
actually used ray tracing to draw something on the
screen so very very exciting stuff hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please don't forget
to hit the like button next time we're basically
going to actually solve the quadratic formula
and see what we can do with that information and
add some shading so that we can actually like
see the form of our sphere and we'll move on from
there thank you guys for watching don't forget to
check out brilliant using my link in description
below and i will see you guys next time goodbye
you